the endless scroll once you'd scroll and
have to click to get to the next page
now the page never ends sucking us
endlessly in we've found that if you
don't give your mind or your brain the
time to catch up with your impulses you
don't get people stopping you so you
just you just keep scrolling something
we didn't realize is we're using our
design techniques and it became so
powerful that it just addicts people
that is leading tech engineers are
asking on the BBC series panorama in the
investigation by our BBC partner Silicon
Valley insiders say our phones are
designed to be addictive and that makes
it harder to disconnect nearly 1 in 10
Americans checks their phone every three
minutes while on vacation and some use
their phone more than 300 times a day
David Pogue is a tech however he is here
with tips on how to unplug during your
summer vacation this is an intervention
[Laughter]
seriously you hear about the amount of
times and minutes that Americans are on
their phones every single day what are
some tips it can get away from that at
least while on vacation so on vacation
obviously if you have the
self-discipline you can go in and turn
off the notifications from the apps that
Bobby most and tempt you most but if you
don't have that self-discipline this is
where these tips come in first of all
announced your family or your companion
what your expectations are say okay I'm
allowed to check the sports scores
before bed I'm allowed to check the news
in the morning but other than that I'm
off the phone and that way you will
guilt yourself and they're allowed to
nag you yeah
secondly if you don't have the ability
to turn on Do Not Disturb or something
like that my wife had this great
suggestion delete the apps Twitter I've
heard people do that deleting Twitter
until they can and of course you know if
you're really pathetic you can reinstall
them on vacation and look but it's got
that one
fiendish behavior greetings deleting and
reinstalling what company is understand
though that self control is one piece of
this but they're also instituting
policies to help their employees wean
themselves uh the big one is Daimler the
German automaker gives you the option
when you go on vacation you're out of
office auto-replies can say by the way
I'm on vacation your email will be
deleted if it's important email me after
August 15th right or send if it's really
important sentence my colleague Anthony
Mason and my point is there's nothing to
stop anyway do that all the time get all
of our emails every month this has
become but but what's interesting here
is that's a work problem but I mean
we're we've spent so much time on our
phones now not just because we're in a
dated with work emails but because of
all this all these social apps were
we're connected to so it's like it and
it keep I mean I love this the idea of
endlessly being sucked in as this guy on
the BBC report says it is a problem I
mean yeah how does how do you you have
to disconnect your social life as well
you do I mean we we are literally
addicted in the medical sense so we get
a little dopamine kick every time we
check every cent time someone likes us
and so on but you can fight apps with
apps so there are these apps like for
Android here's one called
offline it's sort of like a Do Not
Disturb on steroids it blocks all apps
messaging text calls except from the
people you designate as important and
for the iPhone this one called onward is
similar you can put time limits on which
apps you use they give you a report you
need a self-discipline app I mean are
they gonna redesign some of this stuff
in the future knowing what we know now
they are in fact this is the year for
digital health both Apple for the iPhone
operating system this fall and Android
for Android P coming soon both have this
new mode that a tallies up and shows you
how many times a day you wake up your
phone and by the way it's horrifying
yeah average person eighty five times
the average I've been running the beta
and it's like 130 I'm like oh my what's
wrong with it and it also lets you set
time limits for certain apps like no
more than six hours a day on
she would be nervous that we here warm
six hours a day should we be nervous
when we hear more and more of these sex
executives say that they do not let
their kids use these apps and use phones
- you know my feeling is that every
generation has its technological Bugaboo
for their kids right so my parents
weren't allowed to listen to the radio
so much that's right don't watch so much
TV for my kids get your face out of that
phone every generation it's normal it's
human and it's generally over blue well
we are this there's some data on there
about social networks that are just
digital and not physical so it's good to
talk to your friends and not look at
your I'm just saying that different
doesn't mean worse okay David Koch I
decided optimist about all of this